[Music]
there's a trend in many industries to
face a lot of new challenges
every industry now is either undergoing
or is seeing the threat or the promise
of disruption
this program is all about delivering
value for your company getting the
mechanisms to actually drive innovation
in your organization the big challenge i
think is figuring out how to innovate at
large corporations it's exactly what
this program was geared around so it
felt like it was a perfect fit the
program actually brings together three
strengths of the stanford graduate
school of business the first one is
really our expertise
in creating new businesses
the second one is our expertise in
innovation in large organization in a
corporate setting and the third one is
all about the idea of organizational
change
i founded two companies
and now i'm at a big corporate company
the program is ideally suited because it
links the two right my entrepreneurial
spirit with the sometimes obstacles in
big in big corporations
i was looking for something that would
really lead me towards innovation i
really found that the structure of this
program was going to be ideal for me
my role is to be the corporate
entrepreneur and i often find myself in
a place where nobody gets or understands
what i'm thinking or trying to do
and so i wanted to find a place where i
belonged and that i could associate with
other people who were thinking in
similar patterns to me
the project component makes it an
experiential learning and a much more
effective practical experience
these are real projects our participants
bring in the projects some of the
projects become the way to learn by
going through a real project and working
on it and developing it we see the
content from the classroom actually
being applied in a real life setting
where a lot of the learning occurs
the experiential aspect was extremely
important and that's what sets this
program apart from other programs you
get to live
what you learn
and see if it actually works and see if
you can execute on it the cohort is
fabulous we have people from all around
the world
we're all this corporate entrepreneur
who feel that the rest of the
organization doesn't always get us and
some people get us but not everybody and
that we're in this thing together you're
surrounded by people who have
very similar issues you learn a lot from
the experience of others but it also
becomes sort of a support group for for
the corporate entrepreneur which creates
long-lasting networks that are useful in
the future
the world is turning faster even google
now has to take care to keep the speed
and keep the innovation
you need a constant rethinking of your
ideas of new business models a constant
innovation the program helps you take an
idea and develop it evaluate it
communicate it and finally have the
tools to execute on